i'm going to attempt to survive the next
100 days in hardcore minecraft and if i
die at any point
the world is deleted forever
looks like we started off with the
village and a rune portal the first
thing i'm gonna need to survive the full
100 days is a base where i can farm and
sleep it's a pretty standard minecraft
necessity i made my way to the village
first to get some easy resources
gotta make sure i always have food on me
i watch a lot of minecraft speedrunners
and they always do this
look at this guys i'm a minecraft pro
now i could have taken this entire
village as my base but i think we can
all agree that desert biomes are ugly so
i build my own base from scratch instead
according to my calculations we got
about three minutes until night and you
might be wondering
why do i need these shovels it wouldn't
be minecraft if you didn't have a dirt
house it's getting dark move
i now have a dirt house hole i have two
torches so if i put one here and here i
hope bob's don't spawn in here let's see
if it let me sleep
all right we survived the first night
carl literally said there was zero shot
i survived one day eat it carl
oh what is that yeah you're not sly
it's a big vein of iron and now that i
have some iron the only logical thing to
do is
make a chest plate i don't actually know
what to do now that my base is done i
can spend some time gathering materials
to improve it because we're being honest
it's uh
it's average at best look how much wood
i have time to get building
so i spent all of day number three
building this house three emeralds for
kelp
uris fraud and i did the same thing on
day number four
and day five and day six
oh oh yeah you thought you're gonna kill
me all you did was light yourself on
fire
i just built this house on top of my
other house i want to build another
house on top of this house day seven
day eight and also day nine that's right
i put a ton of time into this house and
now that my house is uh
better it's time to make another portal
so we're gonna put water here and we're
gonna put lava on it
and shall we please give me a good spawn
please give me a good spawn
i didn't spawn over a pool of lava
secure the portal
i think i need a bow and arrow before i
go get some glowstone
oh it's nighttime i'm going to sleep on
day number nine
i've officially survived 10 days in
hardcore minecraft
only 90 more to go i need flint for
arrows so i'm just gonna keep laying
this and then breaking it
having arrows means i could fight mobs
from a distance and that's gonna be
super useful in the nether because of
these things
now we're on day 13. as you can see none
of this here is flat
i'm gonna fix that
[Music]
mining and laying dirt takes longer than
i thought it would yep
i just spent a day and a half just
leveling my base
i don't care what you think after
leveling my base on day 15 i figured it
was a good idea to start exploring caves
for some diamonds
exploring started off fine but remember
this is hardcore minecraft and if i die
the world gets deleted
forever i almost walked into that
after my near-death experience i killed
some skeletons mined some iron ore
and then found gold i don't know why i
was so happy
and then after 15 whole minecraft days
i finally found my first diamond
wait diamonds i found my first diamonds
how many did we get
three four five and five diamonds means
i can finally make a diamond pickaxe
bazinga from day 18 to 23 i did not stop
mining for any reason
it's literally been like five minecraft
days of non-stop digging
hey there little guy kind of feel bad
killing it it's kind of cute
love your balls you have nice balls i'm
mine for five straight freaking days
until i found some diamonds
if i didn't go down one i would have
found this diamonds that took forever
oh oh oh it's an eight maid
i went to sleep on day 24 which means i
woke up i am now a quarter of the way
done
oh what is that oh spotter this is big
big
this spawner is just below my base which
means later on i can use it as an xp
farm rod and flesh thank you for that
you're probably wondering mr bc just
spit like a trillion days mining that is
correct and the fruit of my labor is in
this chest
look at all this redstone stacks on
stacks of iron
lapis gold this is glorious and will
allow us to do tons of cool stuff
on day 28 a trader came to my house and
attempted to scam me black dye
seeds pumpkin seeds bring good traits
next time
idiot and on days 29 and 30 i started
gathering materials to build an
enchantment table
now we need to make a book bada-boom
a horse i have an enchantment table and
now we need tons of books which require
paper
and leather on day 32 carl texted me
that he was bored so i told him to hop
on minecraft and join us
carl welcome to the world hey
so carl it is currently day number 32 of
100.
jesus right over here is our house on a
house on a house
this is terrible just for that ah
wait if i die i'm out there's one more
swing i forgot
i'm not the only one on hardcore carl
and i spent all of day 32 and 33
leveling my base
yeah digging baby yes
i called a friend to come help me level
my base and as you can see the lands are
flatter than ever
day 33 came to an end and on day 34 carl
made a landmark discovery
oh it's a sand temple it could have like
a lot of good stuff
i'm coming but while we started
traveling to the desert temple
we realized it was getting dark oh we
shouldn't be out here oh god hurry wait
wait wait let's go to the village and
then sleep in the beds of the village
okay where's the village there's a
creeper
oh god they're skeletons get out the bed
get out of the bed
we finally made it to the village safely
and slept for one night finally it's
time for me and carl to risk our dumb
lives by going into the desert temple
dig down here and then just destroy the
pressure plate just right
there you happy mom now we can see
what's in here oh
golden apple this is my like safety net
and after getting the treasure we made
our way back to the base
before i can relieve you of your duties
i need you to help me build milk shelves
around this thing whoa let's do it
you can't bone meal sugar cane
i have 34 sugar cane and counting yeah i
have eight
so on day 36 we made the sugar cane into
paper and a bunch of leather from the
cows on my farm
cha ching cha chao kapow moment of truth
carl
i put the pickaxe in put the lapis in
level 30 what do i get
efficiency 4 silk touch and um breaking
3.
that's pretty nice i enchanted my iron
armor for the time being and finally on
day 37 it was time to say goodbye to
carl
carl buddy thank you for coming out bye
jimmy i wasn't alone for too long though
because on day 38 chris joined to help
out chris
yeah welcome to the world today's day 38
chris didn't know this but i had big
plans for him to help me out in the
nether things are going to get a little
crazy
if i die it is 100 your fault there's
like a hundred pigmen in a hole right
here joe there's three of these
oh i don't have going on oh crap i
forgot if you don't have gold on dude
jimmy let me back in jimmy let me back
in
chris put gold boots on so the piglets
didn't attack him and we got to work
making the base of the nether more
secure but as you can see
there is some holes ah what where's the
[ __ ] oh
we're still building i'm at half health
from that and i have full
armor on oh he's right outside the bank
oh
sniper oh one shot we tried our best to
make the nether a little safer but
everything just wanted to kill us chris
watch out big piggy big piggy
oh i'm on soul sand oh god half damage
everything was trying to end this
hardcore run even chris
himself oh jimmy
chris i'm actively building chris must
have forgot that if i die
the world gets deleted forever
oh oh god i can't sprint don't mind me
just mining glowstone above a giant pool
of lava
i can't i can't my hands are sweating
get me off here get me off here chris
and i agreed that it was best to get
back home
asap before we died in the nether once
we got back we spent all of day 42
setting up the glowstone around the
house and on day 43
chandler joined before i even thought
about going back to the nether i
desperately needed diamond armor so me
and the boys hit the mines whichever one
of you finds the most diamonds in the
next three minecraft days
i'll give you a firm handshake all right
let's go
and while the boys are collecting
diamonds i need to find a way to get
more levels
as the boys mind i went back to the
spawner beneath my base chris gave up on
mining and became allergic to the nether
but on day 47 everything that could go
wrong went wrong
huh chandler was surrounded by mobs
and chris kept making mistakes with lava
in the nether
oh lava spreads way farther oh i might
die don't die chris
oh i'm good and on day 48 minutes after
chris's recent mistake
well just play the clip
you had one job chris i was trying to
make it look really pretty and i was
focused get away from me everything's
just going wrong since you walked in the
room
hey chandler hey it is now officially
day 50 i'm halfway done
you want to stick the next 50 days out
with me no
bye on day 51 i logged in and my
chickens were everywhere
where did these chickens come from so i
spent the entire day gathering them back
into my farm
days 52 and 53 was just a bunch of
organizing
and on day 54 i built a minecart track
to the mines
it works very well awesome now that
we've crossed 50 days it's time to get
serious about leveling up
i needed to not only upgrade my weapons
but also needed to set up an xp
farm to get op enchanted materials
diamond chest plate
protection four i'm not dying now after
enchanting my diamond chest plate on day
58 i went to finish my xp farm so i
could enchant more armor but
nothing was working to keep the mobs
dying in the same spot they could still
get through
what i even watched a bunch of youtube
tutorials but nothing was cutting it
today is day
69 the day i conquered the spider
spotter i hope funny number
and after 11 whole days i finally got a
working xp
form it works i finally worked oh my
gosh there's so many spiders
so i went back to the base and on day 70
i tested my hard work by enchanting a
pickaxe
yes fortune 3. now i can use this when i
find diamonds to get more diamonds
with fortune on my side it's time for a
few days of diamond hunting
diamond we have this fortune pick
four i mined five diamonds and got 16
diamonds
that sentence didn't make much sense but
even with a fortune 3 pickaxe luck isn't
always on our side
oh oh no no was that literally just one
diamond
and going to sleep on day 74 means that
we're three quarters of the way done
i crowded some diamond pants and tested
my luck more by enchanting them
bada boom bada bing chap my luck was
running pretty dry at this point
on day 81 i decided to build a new base
because it kept bugging me that carl
said my current base was ugly
and boom the house is done i feel like i
cheated on my beautiful house over here
it's got to go and i ended up not liking
my new base so i blew it up we'll put
one
right here just for fun should probably
leave goodbye house
i missed one hey what's going on over
here oh
oh no no wait this is hardcore now you
can't respawn
i see that now techno died immediately
because he didn't know this was a
hardcore run
thankfully his brother had an alt
account take two i am a new person that
is not technoblade i'm tired of this
house so now we need to build another
house on top of it
i'm down for real we only have 16 days
left let's get the building
techno and i spent all of day 84
building another story on my base
oh that looks pretty good but then i
realized there wasn't an easy way to get
down so i did this
so you're telling me if i jump off right
now i will not die uh
if i die that means i have to literally
restart 15 hours of work
it looks like i'm on a roll surviving
risky decisions because of that techno
and i prepared to go into the nether to
get some ender pearls and blaze rods we
wanted to defeat the ender dragon
techno brother we're about to enter the
nether we should make a shield first
shield these nuts let's go okay
so if i fall i just instantly throw this
take your time to throw it
oh i'm this quick when i said take your
time
my hands are so sweaty and while tecno
and i were putting our lives on the line
and the nether
i decided to ask him some really
important questions have you ever tried
a
mr beast burger i have not no come back
i can check on doordash mr beast come
back despite techno not answering the
questions right because everyone should
order a piece burger we're on day 90. it
is officially day 90 which means we only
have 10 days left
that's how math works i hate him and on
this day after
three whole days of searching we finally
found another fortress speed bridge time
speed bridge oh my god oh my oh
no no tactile tecto luckily had a fire
resistant potion
but it was his only one i don't learn
from my mistakes let's go
is that a skeleton not even a flinch oh
there's no way an actual skeleton is out
here in the middle of the lava
oh my god there's actually a skeleton
here yo
got your back
oh my god
oh god i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead it's
over no you just left me in the middle
of the nether
you were my guardian so i let techno's
brother's brother joined with a
different account
totally not still technoblade all right
i've changed my skin no one will know
i'm technoblade
oh now i have to journey back across the
fire lake without fire rest maybe you
should wait for me to get there
nope already doing it i really shouldn't
have booked it without techno because
i've literally poured dozens of hours
into this video already
and if i died it was all for nothing
techno and i met back up and with only
five days left we realized there was no
way we could beat the ender dragon in
time
i do have a nice compromise mr beast
this is a baby and this is a cliff
say no more sac the crew sacrifice
bye oh wait oh it's mom's hitting oh my
god it's mom
it's mom she did not like that she did
not like that
so we just went to bed and woke back up
on day 96. it's day 96. yo
guys you don't even understand i've been
playing on this world for over 20
hours i don't know it doesn't seem that
long to me it is because you just joined
i think my willpower is just stronger
and these last few days were honestly
the hardest part of the challenge i was
dying for it to be over
doors in a field doors in a field
doors in a field time to sleep this is
me sleeping on day 98 which means it's
now day 99
the last day of this entire series
techno
it's the final day of the series we're
almost free
you're actually free to leave at
literally any point oh sick i'm out
techno and i built a memorial crafted a
cake made a table and waited for the sun
to set
on this glorious day techno has his
horse we have our cake the sun is
winding down the only thing missing
is the chickens come here chickens join
us
join us i think it's time we end the
series i think it is too let's go to bed
yo it's over i'm going to bed